the outer bands of hurricane florence
will start to impact the north carolina
coast
this morning here's what the storm looks
like from space
sustained winds are peaking at 110 miles
an hour but the most dangerous threat
comes from
storm surge that will hit the carolinas
tonight and tomorrow
chief weathercaster lonnie quinn of our
new york station wcbs tv
shows how the two threats work together
lonnie good morning
well good morning everyone now as
hurricane florence gets closer and
closer to land
i want to focus on two primary impacts
and that's going to be wind
and storm surge so this storm is going
to batter the coast on friday the peak
winds
of 100 miles per hour or more extend
only about 20 miles from the center of
the storm that's your eye wall
and outside of this there's a band of
hurricane force winds that extends
70 miles from the eye here's where
you're going to find winds that are
almost 74 miles per hour or stronger
the rest of this entire storm is
primarily tropical storm force winds and
those are winds that are over 39 miles
per hour and they extend
220 to 245 miles from the center
now keep in mind you can always get a
stronger gust at any point in time but
there's also another element of the
storm and it's the temperature
of that water below florence it is a
bathtub it is 85 degrees
that will help to maintain the strength
as well and it also matters
what side of the storm you are on the
worst part of the storm
is the front right quadrant and that's
because you get the highest winds the
most tornadoes and the storm
pushes that water onto the shore on the
left hand side of the storm the water is
actually pushed
away from the coast and most people
unfortunately die from storm surge than
any other part of a hurricane and in
this storm
that water could rise 15 feet that's
basically
up to the second floor of a home and
that's why now is the time that those
folks have got to evacuate if you're in
the north carolina south carolina
tidewater area look at this the
tidewater area could see that 10 to 15
foot surge from plymouth
all the way to moorhead city nora all
right lonnie thank you